so I know some of you in batter you're
heading into this one it starts off
harmlessly enough seems like everything
else and then you super play out and
then you get to a point and start
scratching your head okay so just for
the sake of it maybe um since before you
had trouble at the beginning or you're
not sure if your beginning was right or
not let's start out so first step in
induction voice test okay so it's a
pretty easy one
yeah ah N squared plus three sorry once
once my ends 1 cubed
it's acute toothless that what's that
okay so one point zero two it's equal to
six and sure enough that's divisible at
least I hope so net okay so it's true
for gentlemen it's true for the first
allowable vote yes true for gentlemen
also true for anyway okay so now I
assume um by the way I've actually I've
noticed for myself and this will become
important later on um I've been a bit
sneaky and been forgetting to declare an
important part of this in other
questions with the solving hasn't been
that important but it is divisibility
ones it's vital okay I'll work every
time you introduce a value or pronumeral
right a variable you need to give it
some conditions right we've been doing
about some of them but I've noticed I've
been forgetting one so my bad you might
need to go back through some of you
again add it in but what we assumed is
statement that it's true for it equals
okay I've been forgetting we've got this
cave right and we haven't say anything
about the cave okay now um in this case
the only condition that we need to meet
is the K is an integer okay
sometimes later on it'll be K is an
integer and it's this big okay
sorry it's a positive integer for some
more later ones we can look at
particularly fit inequalities it only
works for values like them six seven
eight
that's the standard okay so we need to
introduce some conditions about it
assume true for N equals K so ie K cubed
plus three K squared plus two K is equal
to six P where and you can introduce
both of these letters at the same time
so I would just say where K and P are
positive okay now the proof proved for
the next value law okay
namely K plus 1 or cubes again be
watchful for your buckets and that's
some other multiple of six okay okay now
where do our where does our proof
actually start to go if we start with
the left hand side it seems like if I
want to bring this here I'm just gonna
have to expand everything out its sure
enough that's where we've got to go to
begin with um you could factorize if you
like I take out the factor of K plus 1
but you're going to have to break out
eventually anyway because you need see
this as a key cubed yeah right
so you need to get the K out of there
right you're gonna have to expand
everything which looks a bit ugly but
it's what you need to be able to
actually substitute associative okay
otherwise you end up with fractions
which is a bad idea
because it's all that divisibility which
is that whole lovers okay so if you
introduce fractions into it you start
undermining your own proof okay so I'm
going to expand
okay now I want to think about how can I
bring my assumption in and I've got a K
cubed in my assumption right so that
looks good I've got one there and I have
one and only one here there are no other
K cubes okay now what they're indicates
to me is that all this other stuff right
is going to have to not be included in
the assumption okay so you're gonna have
to be comfortable with that sort of
awkwardness for a little while while we
simplify it out as far as we can okay
so I want not just the K cubed but I
want the 3 K squared and conveniently I
have one right there okay so these other
this other cakes where right three K
squared it I can't bring it into my
assumption right because I don't have
the numbers book right and then I have a
2 K there so I have a 2 K here so
there's my pieces that I'm going to
substitute you now okay so I'll say
that's equal to 6 P plus and then I've
got all my other bits I might as well
collect like terms so what do I got here
k squared 9 6 by assumption
now this is the stage I wish some of you
will think have I done something wrong
okay because usually the number that
you're after divisible by six right once
you factorize it properly in the
substitutionary assumption you get like
a whole bunch of 6s or a whole bunch of
21s or whatever number it is and you
look at this and you think hmm okay so
what are we going to do with it before
we do with that
let's get these six numbers out of the
way okay so I put my 6p and my six at
the front and then I have these two now
I'm just writing them in brackets just
to make it obvious that I'm saying this
whole thing is divisible by six and I
know that this part is already divisible
six because I have the right numbers
okay if the whole thing is divisible by
six and this part is divisible six it
implies this also being divisible by six
which doesn't seem to seem a bit
counterintuitive okay how does it work
that this is divisible by six now what I
recommend you do because you sort of
right now you have the advantage of me
telling you this is right okay so you
know all right even though it'll tweed
I'm correct if you get this question in
an exam and you're like how do I know
whether this is actually right or wrong
right maybe I just messed up my
arithmetic somewhere to have to go
searching for an answer
okay or are these numbers correct what
do you do if you're saying this is
divisible by six how would you know
throw some value okay you put one in for
instance 1 3 times 1 plus 9 is 12 to
fizzle by 6 okay okay try another one
try to 3 times 4 that's 12 plus 18
that's 12 plus 18 is 30 or should've is
less if you can keep going just to just
to satisfy yourself that wasn't quite
induction but so you can see alright I
haven't gone wrong this is actually
right so I'm not looking for an error up
here I'm just got to deal with this guy
okay so what we're going to do um let's
keep marching on and we'll see if we can
simplify this just a little bit okay I
got a common factor here right namely 3k
okay yeah when you look at this okay so
close
but because you haven't seen is kind of
much before it's kind of like what do I
do um let me put it over here in
different color k plus 3 and okay think
about these two right okay this is why I
said it's very important that we talk
about it k is an integer right here's an
integer so when you think about these
two numbers is a product right any whole
number you like people wondering
different fuzzy serated iron in okay
you'll get an odd number and an even
number or you'll get an even number and
an odd number can you see that okay
because it weighs three apart
so both can't be odd and both can't be
even but one has to be one wants the
other okay so therefore I can say that
this is an even number
okay see the step I mentioned so I'm
actually going to bring that in so am i
working I'm saying it's equal to six P
plus six actually I might include Duncan
but K is an integer right hands I said
this to a few port right
one of these has to be even one of them
at least right hence either K or K + 3
must be even right sit inductions all
that logic okay so therefore I'm going
to say is plus three times two are where
so you are equal to that and I is an
integer okay and now I have my six okay
6p + 6 + 6 r that you can probably take
it from there okay so it's a weird
question because you well you have to
think about it okay it doesn't just
follow the nice four steps you've got to
use your brave right